okay hello everyone we are continuing
our series of design reviews for the
upcoming version 13.3 of awesome
language
and this is a continuation of our review
about sound Vision features and I think
we'd already covered quite a bit of this
we're going to come back to some of that
where should I start here
speech computation in that audio section
you're on okay
okay do I care about this I mean who
have we had requests for the
SE Google services
it's not just Google it's Google and
other ones but the quality of synthesis
and recognition is higher compared to
what we're using now
and eventually we can see having our our
better version of it as well but in the
for the time being
allowing people to connect to those
Services seems reasonable
okay
but don't we aren't we getting our own
networks for these things
it has just been approved by legal
okay
fine
so so then we'll get our own network
right
you're you're in process to produce that
yes well yes it has been approved is in
the pipeline and we'll have to test it
once it is imported but the plan is that
and we'll see if it works out no reason
to suspect they won't but
I guess it might be nice to discuss do
we do we want to have these Services now
and continue supporting them there is I
think four that we have identified and
have some connection to
if we have them then why don't we have
them I mean you know
we've already built them it's okay I
mean we can always tell people nobody's
going to be upset if we have our own
built-in service that works just fine
and we say well you don't now have to do
this authentication nobody's going to be
upset about that
okay
um
okay these are multilingual yes
yes
depends on the service Google I think is
okay
we finally have SVG import I thought we
finally had that a few years ago we had
that last version uh import as image as
a raster image we had now we're
importing it in this version as vector
graphics there are some limitations
part of it depends on front end it's not
huge though a lot of svgs come in just
fine
yeah I mean years ago
we had issues with this dealing with
flag images
working on that what's that remember
that I remember that now that you
mentioned why don't you why don't you uh
point out to that team that we now have
SVG Vector import and see what they can
you know I don't know maybe they'll get
more flags that way okay will do
okay
what is ranged data
um that's when a column can have a range
of values
um it's it's a new element that is being
added now we consider anything out of
that range that can be specified as an
option at a range
oh son
so you mean it can only go from one to a
thousand or something right
and then click beyond that or some or
with some option allow different
behaviors
why do we want this
it's a part of excel specification and
we upgraded our Excel Import in the
previous versions this is one of one
small leftover from that okay okay
um question I mean the whole issue of
recognizing what part of the spreadsheet
actually contains meaningful data how
are we doing on that haven't well I
haven't really started on that we see it
as a collaboration between import export
and machine learning to understand what
part of this data and then move on with
upgrade to semantic import neither of
the two teams had the time to work on
that but I think it's a completely
reasonable thing to tackle
soonish
okay
talking of of um sound whatever has
happened to the music stuff
also no bandwidth for that
but but we really love it as much as you
do it's just a priority
do we continue on video video has been
what we had momentum on and we have
stuck on that
for the past few releases
yeah
I mean I don't think no this chess stuff
I'm not a big fan of
it wasn't the whole time sink
the disjoint resources you can't
all right just because someone is good
at chess doesn't mean they're good at
music
yes Roger
then
um
um what is this
I don't know
okay you want to demo this here
you can run chess player
uh more of those other stop sections I
would say are
brainstorming the four
symbols that Roger has listed on the top
are the four that we are suggesting
going to thirteen three
oh God
okay where do I start here just a talk
you really shouldn't necessarily look at
any of those subsections unless we want
to think
I want to see what it does chess player
bracket bracket and start playing
or go to the source page if you want to
sort of see and then you can pick an
example and edit from there I mean this
is like like I mean I understand that
chess is a thing but it just seems you
know what are we going to do play
Dungeons of dragons next
whom is the plan clearly
yeah I think dungeon Dungeons and
Dragons what's next in our big plan
weird
[Music]
this is weird
why can't I why can't you you're white
you can you know white starts always
that's one of the rules you should try
and do something weird don't necessarily
play well I think this is this is a
rather good tool now you see evaluation
down there
um
you can undo if you don't like that move
of yours
it's magnificent but these are not I
mean I just don't understand the
priority of this
as I said yeah go ahead Roger
it's it's not been a priority this is
completely
uh
passion project outside kind of like
cellular automata or something it's a
passion project wow A lot of it was also
developed before they became projects
with us yeah no no I mean this is
outside of it hasn't been a priority
Stephen really I don't know
um Rafa was the one who started
importing the chess formats in the
previous or I have to say he had the
development for importing chess formats
and then as soon as we committed Jay
from the docs team said I have a chess
player
and then since then we have most of what
Jay has done is cleaning up and
predefying this player that you had
that you see
Alice's work in the cloud
I haven't tested it I don't know you've
got to do that you've got to do oh I'll
test it don't do that I mean I don't
know if it will work
yeah yeah my guess is that it won't work
to begin with but it wouldn't be too
hard to make it work because it's it's
just
well I don't know actually I'll test
how good is the engine I've got to say
anything client server does particularly
worrisome I don't see any reason why I
would failover
okay the integrated chess engine I think
is okay but there's also a plug-in so
you can if you have stockfish which is
the Premier chess engine
you can run against stockfish
um and that's something that
you can download to run on your machine
yes
but we can't or shouldn't include it for
some reason
I think we would have to license it out
okay okay
but but there's some standard interface
to the engine yes that's that UCI there
is a universal chess interface anything
that complies with that we can work with
well okay how do I get
I mean how do I get
something that is us computable out of
this
now under the new game there is next to
the new game in your interface there is
a drop down now you can save your game
um currently we save to a PGN but I
guess
we care about is some kind of symbolic
representation of the game where you can
actually do some computation as opposed
to just you know oh
I'm just playing a game just for fun
which is right not what we do I mean
that's where chess game and chess sport
objects come into play
those are the other two objects we have
um there are ref pages for all four of
these that you're seeing
and then I was thinking it would be nice
to say I pick the next 10 moves uh from
an engine and then
um I can add one of those moves to my
current chess board or chess game and
get a new border again I want to get the
game graph
from somewhere right
how would I do that
I mean
currently all all the moves what's what
gets stored in a game is it is a
sequence of moves and you can you can
we can visualize that what's this
um that's because probably we evaluated
it earlier
well so but why that can't generate a
message right no for sure I'll look into
that it might be just an older GUI but
I'll look into it
oh boy
what the hell no we can't do that
that's not implemented yet that's what I
said the chessboard recognized we have
an implementation of it but chessboard
plus a move that that's something that
is up for discussion I I don't think
it's crazy
why do you think it's crazy
because I don't know what else is Plus
you know if we're gonna do plus like
that doing plus with strings would make
a lot more sense that's a lot more
useful
don't do this okay do this do this sure
why
I mean we could consider plus with
strings I don't know how much stuff we
break by doing that
we'd probably break a ton of stuff by
doing that
by having that be append
you mean string join
yeah string join
okay
oh but I guess append a chess game comma
and move could be could be one thing we
could do but but in general I was
thinking chess game what's in the
oh you can open the rest Pages chess
chess game is basically a sequence of
moves and a bunch of metadata
why isn't the list of moves
just a plain list of moves in that first
argument
yeah I would think so or one of the keys
could just be moves and then so those
two moves that's what it is symbolic
representation of a move
there are different notations there is
the standard notation I know I know I'm
asking
you know
a notation that says you know F1 C4 or
something
is not our kind of computable
representation
it's like the relationship
you go ahead no I mean it's like a regex
you know some compressed regex type form
as opposed to something which is
actually usable I mean like I want to
know
let me draw the trajectory of every Pawn
okay how do I do that
so I'm asking I mean without writing
without taking apart strings and stuff
like that mm-hmm
that's not something we had thought
about or is in this proposal but I do
see that I know but I mean the the thing
is this is just like
you know it's like the emacs editor
having a game of life built into it you
know it's just one of these things
that's kind of weird
it'd be one thing if this was actually
set up to be
you know
I mean it's kind of like
you know the the whole sort of
computable games thing I mean you know I
wrote this whole piece about
about game graphs and so on right why do
we have tic-tac-toe in the thing as well
why don't we have hangman why don't we
have
you know Monopoly why don't we have um
uh you know I don't know what
I mean this is much more
I mean I don't know the the you know
this is just computable game stuff in
this case tic-tac-toe
okay I mean there's somebody uh some
student at the summer school who did uh
this comfortable things with chess
right
but I mean that's not which is a mini
mini mini version of Chess I think chess
as it is
right
oh
I don't know what to think of this I
mean I honestly I'm I'm
I mean as you know wfr like
functionality A-Okay as built-in stuff
it's it's just kind of weird
um
could as well be it packlet repository I
guess at this point if you really don't
want it built in
I kind of think that's a better place
for it right now I mean I feel like if
we're going to build it in it's kind of
like got to be one of like in Wolf and
Alpha right we have a bunch of
information about all kinds of games
did you even know that
I knew that yeah
just like meta information no right
that's correct
I mean
you know let's say I want to take a
chess game
what's this chess tools backtick what
the hell is that about that's just yeah
that's just because we put it in the
context until design review happens
well promoted to system once approved so
I'm gonna ask you some questions here so
this let's say we do this
and I import this game
oh
that's bad
it worked yesterday
no I don't know whether I have
maybe I don't have the most recent
version
let me quickly check in today's while
you're checking your your version is
okay I'm two days and it works
all right well
maybe this thing here will will work I
don't know let's take a look
maybe works okay all right so now
I want to get a picture of the sequence
of boards from this how do I do it
what the hell is this date why is that
not on our standard date format
what is this
that's a good point yeah I actually
yeah that should be cool and why are
these not entity names no why are those
not entities they will become entities
as soon as you ask for that specific if
you ask for meta game or yeah assign
that to a variable or just say percent
then property gain I'm sorry metadata
then we do the interpretation at that
point we didn't make them entities in
the summary box because it's slow to
interpret them why is it slow to
interpret them not not after they've
been made into entities
reverse some slowness that should be
fixed
but then you're saying at the time we
import this chess game which a PGN file
could be hundreds of chess games we
should interpret every name well I I
don't know I I don't know I I it's
reasonable to me but we thought this is
kind of a okay compromise we show
whatever is stored exactly
yeah I think there's a lot of you know
all of these things make this a packlet
not a built-in thing
every time you tell me there's a hack
I'm going to tell you you know then it
doesn't I mean like why is that not you
know what why is that
I mean I don't know what that even means
and and that's like why is that on an
entity
well if I play a game at my home that
can't be an entity right not not
everything can be a vanity well that's
perhaps your location
we know the geolocation
again not explicitly stored in the file
we can we we have other functionality
for people to say interpret this site
and give me a geolocation for that show
me the list sequence of boards
as sequence of boards I didn't think
about it it wouldn't be hard to add we
have the rules
compute the sequence reports how do I
get the sequence boards how do I get the
signals to move so get game States here
just
um
if you ask for moves
okay
okay now how do I get the sequence of
game States yeah
um
how do I apply a move to a to a game to
a game state
uh we can't we thought about actually
um why not I mean you've got an engine
that can do it with all kinds of weird
guise
and apply it to a game state
uh and you applying applying it to a
game State you mean exactly what I
thought as adding it to a game state to
a chess board actually yes but and I
also want to know I mean that adding is
also silly because some of these are not
compatible you can't do that move right
right
how do I take axb5
and I say you know
um and write that out as you know night
to you know Queen six or something
whatever that whatever the terminology
is the change of annotations you mean or
notations no I want to know what's the
human readable version
where
you you know when you when you see this
written out there's a human readable
version that's sort of a whole sentence
well that's a great suggestion we we
don't have it now okay but if you're
getting excited about those things we
can get them at it no no I'm I'm telling
you this is not well thought out that's
the main thing I'm telling you okay
not not claiming it's well thought of
it's uh okay look it's a great packlet
it's not something for the system yet
I mean let's get it as a packlet
let's
plan on having this you know
it's a magnificent packlet
but you know the thing I'm telling you
is
this needs some symbolic representation
we can absolutely use this short form
just like we do with reg X's
that's what I'm saying
did you understand what I'm saying yes
but it needs some symbolic form where I
could compute like I want to be able to
take this game and I want to be able to
plot where the pawn you know where a
particular piece moved and you know
Progressive with time
that's super difficult to do from what
you have here essentially impossible
so I'm saying I have to I might as well
go back to the original chess you know
import format to do that am I making
sense
we have the fence that we can extract
from the whole sequence of moves their
fan strings that Fen was a format we
introduced before okay so what I don't
care I mean it's like I want to get
you know give me
the you know the White Queen I want to
see where did the White Queen move on
the board
right
I don't think you can tell me that
that's not our kind of computable system
it's just you know
it's something very different you're
you're right some some query like that
yeah I know that's what it means to be
computable this isn't
it's a you know it's a hack into a chess
playing program
it's just fine but not what we would
normally have in the system
makes sense there are there are things
there are still things that are really
computable like getting a score for
every step of the game and then yes
Fisher will show me in this game show me
the scores as a function of time
um
is it scores what is it
yeah I'm trying to
uh score to me okay well no I'm I I'm
not arguing that this is really complete
if you can give me the score time series
basically or the list of scores here
right then that's another thing I can
compute with as it is right now
what am I doing with this I mean like
for example let's say I want to find out
which moves involve a bishop
I think that's what a b means is that
right well we have no idea
yeah
okay but I mean then I'm hacking strings
right
you are and one piece of our future
proposal was that we could even have
things you know another symbolic
representation in this world could be a
move and a chess move I think would make
a lot of these queries that you're
making easier to to find
then the game becomes a list of moves
yep
but I mean I just don't see how do I get
the the sequence of boards corresponding
to this game
I'm I'm well I'm just trying to get that
and for some reason I'm failing to do
that
um chess chess board is supposed to work
with a fence string and I'm mapping that
over
the list of fan strings and that doesn't
work I don't know why is it a board
State that's a board State yes okay so
how do I get the fun strings from this
just uh as a property say fans f-e-n
Capital lowercase s
some something wrong in your prototype
I'm getting a list of strings
okay
this is a wonderful packlet that's where
it should be for now
and that's you know if we want to
develop this towards something which
will be part of the system it's got to
have these things that we're describing
of of having
a sort of full explicit symbolic form
excellent okay
not just strings like this
it's like then when we do tic-tac-toe
we'll invent our own string notation
like this and nobody will ever
understand it
can you get chest tools packlet and see
if you're if everything starts working
in your build
packlet or yeah that that's it just
evaluate that and go back to the chat to
the input field above
okay so again all right
okay magnificent okay so now what do I
do with these
okay now
now uh just map chest tools back to
chess board over that list
uh lowercase b
what's that
I mapped it what the heck
I
don't know sorry sorry sorry sorry
we're waiting we're waiting we're
waiting
well what the heck what are the
so that that's a currently proposed type
setting for a chessboard if you open any
of those summary boxes you see a
graphics rendering but that is also a
property of those chessboard objects we
can
graphics
yeah
this is not properly thought through I'm
sorry it's not properly thought through
okay now what how would I take these
and
for example
how would I superimpose these so I can
see you know with some opacity
do you get what I'm saying
uh over time you want to make a video or
just everything on top of each other
I'm I'm happy with everything on top of
each other so can I just say show
um yup that would do it without any
opacities
uh well that's not very useful because
it's only showing the last thing stack
them all up and showed the last thing so
how can I get it with opacity I would
say what could I do could I say opacity
of one of these
no no opacity doesn't work with Graphics
yeah you have to probably you have to
inject the pasta inside of each of the
graphics so if you yeah okay so it's a
list list
this probably should work this thing
that that um
something like that
just like it does with a color
maybe that's crazy
probably
well Graphics I think it's crazy for
image that could work and just call said
Alpha Channel
yeah
well I mean I presumably could do this
if I said in in this case here I mean
but you know
the whole point is the point I'm making
is this isn't very computable this is
basically pictures
it's quite nice but it's it's not ready
it's not ready
are you going to try and disagree with
that or not
one well I guess one meta question is
that do we ever want to have this
stem and once it's ready possibly okay
do we want to make that appearance
gradual or do we want everything to be
super ready we've we've done gradual
introduction ready it's not ready it's
not the right design it's not ready
okay okay
do I have to say that any more clearly
there's a million things here that are
not thought through that are not set up
so that they can be you know so they can
interoperate with other things and so on
right
so how do I do the set Alpha channel
here
um I'm actually just a second looking at
image compose and trying to figure out
if we can just more easily do that with
image compose
it requires some yeah no we can't have a
list of opacities for all of us
but said Alpha Channel yeah if you map
thread set off a channel slot come up
or a kind of a Mac index oh you want
everything everything okay yeah just do
that
okay and then what do I do then I just
say image compose or yeah just image
compose should do it
all right
image yeah no I realize that image
compose requires a background so maybe
the first stuff well and I'm just adding
these images I don't understand why am I
not just adding these images so why
don't I just say applied Plus
to present 19. there will be a white
image maybe do mean of person 19 19.
why would it be a white image
because you're adding all of those
intensities it soon goes above one when
you add images
mean instead of Plus
just sorry just mean of percent 19.
foreign
okay
I mean that's slightly amusing
how do I I could if I say image adjust
how do I make it darker yeah
darker
yeah the function darker
that's not what I wanted
foreign
I have to tell you it gets pretty
exciting pretty soon what uh that this
whole chess chess business that we're
adding
um you're already hooked into it to some
extent too just I I completely agree
it's not ready but I don't see why it
can't be a gradual introduction of this
in this but we're not going to like many
other things we haven't thought through
properly sure okay fine I mean
you know like for example can I do
something where I have you know voxels
where it's black and white voxels
you see what I'm saying
stacked here how would I do that
I I cannot imagine what you're asking
for sorry no no no I'm I want to show in
each successive thing I want to show the
black Army on the side the white Army on
the side and as we go down a stack of
pixels right
I want to show the black Army you know
diffusing out to the the other side type
thing get what I'm saying
still no oh think about these boards
okay and think of stacking them in 3D
space
think of turning every black piece to a
black voxel every white piece to a green
voxel or something you know
okay and then slice by slice show them
yeah we're showing each each board State
I kind of like he plots seller automata
like a 2d Cellar automata evolving over
time yeah this is kind of like that but
you know but so you need to stack them
up a little bit probably have I don't
know 15 pixels High per game state right
so if you're just making an array plot
3D if I can just extract from this okay
I mean the point is these games are not
huge so there's no there's nothing you
know storing the thing in an association
with lists this and that and the other
is not difficult
right so there's a dense representation
there's a sparse representation of each
one of these things I'm making sense
and it should be possible to just get
you know the I mean I don't know exactly
it requires thinking it through you know
how do you get if you have the dense
representation you have something which
it says a list and you have blanks and
you have um you know a piece a
representation of each piece that's one
thing or you can have a sparse
representation we just say that the
location of each piece and so on and
then
you know and then you should be able to
search for the you know
the kind of thing I'm talking about
namely
you know
the path of a piece the stack of you
know black and white cells uh perhaps
something about you know the set of all
possible moves from a given place you
know these kinds of things that that we
have from a chessboard already you have
properties like legal moves or even best
moves which comes from
so if I if I go if I take
one of those chessboard objects
okay if I take near the end of the game
here
I take this thing
and I ask for legal moves can I do that
um it might be a today's feature thing
ask for properties and see if you have
it okay great
that's nice that's cool it's quite cool
and and you can ask for best move or
best three moves no no but this this
allows you to make a multi-way graph
exactly so so for each of these how do I
apply each of these moves uh you can't
do that can you that we don't have tell
me how how we can inject it I don't know
I don't know I'm telling you this needs
an actual look
I don't know I mean
a chess game is a complete history
a chessboard is an instantaneous state
I don't understand why what you're doing
isn't
like a chessboard
chess game can be a list of chessboards
yep
I actually think chess boards is a
property of chess game and if it's not
okay the fundamental problem here is
these are lovely you know ra6 plus is
lovely
but it's not relevant for our language
okay what's relevant for our language
and what could come out here is
something which is a representational a
bunch of moves each one is a summary box
it could say ra6 Plus at the top but the
whole point is it's got some internal
symbolic representation
I completely agree I think moves could
be added as a symbol
yeah and why don't you work on the
packlet for this and then let's pick
this up again in you know in a few
months perhaps and I you know I do think
it would be
a nice source of example data if we can
really make it computable but this is
not that
do you get what I'm saying
and we should just think through
you know other board games I don't know
go this stuff yeah though I don't know
what would be my yeah next pick as far
as at least complexity and popularity I
think that's
that's the next
um tic-tac-toe you know sure sure that's
simpler and also beautiful simpler but I
mean I I don't know what and if we have
a symbolic representation I mean you
could even look at that blog post of
mine where I have exactly that for like
Tic-tac-toe and a bunch of these other
games
right
um
yeah I
I'm rolling my eyes slightly because I
you know we've got so many critical
things to do and
it's like
fine this is amusing
but I wish it was done in a way that was
more kind of rather than just sort of
hacking in a chess program here
I don't think what we have done is a
whole lot of hack but your feedback I
think is nice I I I think we should do
more we can do more
and that's if you want to wait on
releasing in the system that's fine by
me we do sure that's fine okay all right
let's go back to what else we had to
look at today
how am I going to store this
so we have a section A whole thing
called chess I think we're going to end
up having to do that because where would
it go what what guide page would it go
on
I was thinking about that not sure and
we're getting bucks for it I was
thinking do we want it chess
category of bugs
um or or games
I I don't know it all depends how much
do we think we want to continue on that
and we see how popular the packet is but
I mean I think I think it's nice and fun
and I don't see any problem with that
but and I think especially our user base
is excited about Chess in particular
games I think in general sure
to some extent I mean yes but I mean
it's like why would they come to us to
play a game of chess unless they can do
things which are the kinds of things
that we can do that your average you
know game engine
you know chess engine that will fit on a
phone can't do
right and the answer is all sorts of
interesting visualizations analysis etc
etc yes exactly that's exactly how this
whole project started yeah but we don't
have that here I mean just the import of
pgns allowed brothel who was the
advocate for the for this whole thing
imported his own games and see how he's
improving as he's playing
well there is the one number you get
from uh like chess.com that says how
good you are in comparison to others but
it doesn't tell you that move in that
game was really nice or you have started
making less bad moves in your games it
doesn't give you any other details and
that's why he started this whole project
okay for some reason this
Community post is not working anymore
that's really weird
it's really freaking weird
this is a summer school project
multi-way gas minimal chess and games
that works but then why
what's going on now
well who knows
um
I mean a good test case for this would
be
uh
no well we could take this and we could
try and do some end game type
multi-way graphs see what they're like
but you know for that we got to have
things like apply this move otherwise it
can't work
see what I'm saying yep
okay let's go to our other part of our
agenda and the time that remains I you
know uh Bob is here as well
okay let's go back to what we were
talking about before which I think is
much more important okay okay
so
can you uh describe this
so we started by talking about how we
convert manipulates into
um videos and the one thing that we
specifically talked about last time or
you mentioned was how do we make
voiceovers for these videos cases like
no caption let's let's be clear on what
we're trying to do here so I mean we
might say I'm going to go to the
demonstrations project
um
actually needs a faceless but it's
homepage but anyway
um
all right let's take
a random one of these
okay let's say copy to cut board this is
a lovely mechanism
okay there's my manipulate and I want to
go like this I'm going to say well you
know here we're showing more steps now I
want to show this with an obtuse
triangle okay let's show up with stars
let me increase the number of steps
there nice demonstration by the way but
right so I'm I want to give some voice
over here but but maybe what I want to
do I just don't know how one produces a
video from this
Bob might have a comment about that
in other words we if if we say if you
say to me
there are these control I don't know
what the controls look like we can take
a look
okay so let's say that I want to script
for myself
something with a series of of um
uh I don't know what it is even steps
here I want to say step one step two
step three and each one of them is going
to last a second or something like this
or a half a second or whatever it is
and then I'm going to say you know I'm
going to show dots I'm going to show
Suns
whatever
and
how would I normally
how would this normally be done Bob if
you were making a video of this what
would you do
traditionally we would capture it
manually
um and then clean up the capture as much
as we could with a lot of masking and
then the voiceover would be red and
overlaid and like Premiere and then
exported so there's a good amount of
steps yeah okay but what I'm asking is
this that what we can do here is script
the thing with time marks
okay I don't understand how that relates
to a voiceover
how does one do that because I mean I
you know if you say you've got 1.5
seconds to read these two sentences I
don't know if I can do that in 1.5
seconds
um
no not 1.5 seconds no but I understand I
understand my point is this
if we are writing a script here that
says
this is what I I'm trying to understand
what we would want to do it's like for
example
we could have something where somebody
we could have first of all synthesized
voices are coming
um
and you know if we say for example here
let's say we say speech synthesize I
mean I think we should assume that the
synthesized voices will be here soon
enough
um you know and let's say we say speech
synthesized this is a Thailand let's see
more steps
okay
so it would need to know the duration
overall duration of the video in just a
like a waypoint or or time marker to
know when to start reading that yeah but
right but so so the thing
the thing would be I would imagine what
we would do is we would say you know in
the script so to speak what we were
doing is we'd be saying this is the
state of the you know what we what we do
is something like this
we'd say but it's a little tricky
because you know we would say this is
the state
this is the voiceover but somehow the
voice over
ah do you got do you get the point I'm
making I mean you could say here's a
state static it's a shot of some kind
right then you say yak yak yak over that
shot
right then you change to another shot
you say yak yak
right and we could do that here in
by saying
this is this these are the collection of
settings at this time mark this is the
voiceover that begins at that time mark
Charlie does that make sense to you
so in other words we're giving time
marks and dispersed by voiceovers we're
not saying what those times actually are
3.2 seconds whatever we're just saying
you're composing this thing where you're
in this state you read this after you've
finished reading that you go to the next
state so to speak so sun has Sun reads
one part of the script star when we get
to Star it
does the next part exactly okay good but
I mean so that would be that's more like
the slideshow mechanism right
so you know if we go to
uh
what the heck is that
what on Earth
slideshow video
what is going on here
you had one casing different
you're I don't care I I want to know why
it's spinning like that oh please
support that as a bug we weren't seeing
your spinning yeah well right so please
report that as a bug in the Prototype
build
okay okay so Bob I don't know if you've
used these things what the heck is it
doing look at this what is it doing is
there some Dynamic that's that's frozen
here
okay so here we've got a slideshow video
last five seconds it shows those three
slides
okay so what I'd like to know is it's
already possible shoddy if I want to say
this is the earth here's a speedboat
you know Etc et cetera et cetera can I
do that how would I do that you can do
that uh you could speech synthesize the
three things
so no we then so these are will be two
separate steps you speech synthesize the
things you join them figure out their
durations
that's why we already lost the game
because what I want to be able to do is
I want to be able to say this is the
voiceover for this slide this is the
voiceover for the slide that is not
possible at the moment but that is it
like two lines of code okay fair enough
great
all right so now what I want to know
is
you know and this is a question kind of
for Bob about how video how scripts work
okay if we've got static slides I
understand you have a voiceover for one
slide you change slides you have a
voiceover for the next slide and so on
right so now the question is what if you
have a dynamic thing that's moving from
here to there and as it moves you want
to be saying you know and now we
increase the number of steps blah blah
blah and you're saying that while this
is moving you get what I'm saying
is there a standard way in kind of you
know movie scripts or whatever video you
know to represent that thing
in other words I I you know I've seen in
scripts I've seen you know there's a
picture of you know there's a you know
the the the
um the person is on a horse Galloping
from here to there and then there's a
bunch of dialogue that's written there
right a storyboard
um yeah typically it's a storyboard or
it's just an all text outline script and
that's in traditional editing that's
what informs what goes where
I understand but so for our purposes so
you understand what I'm saying that we
would have something where you're going
we've got
series
guys that walk me through how we're
planning to do this so I've got one
thing as waypoints that you can Define
am I making sense
states of states of the manipulate that
we can Define Charlie are you with me
yes
and that's bookmarks or time marks that
we were looking at like but how do you
go between those time marks
is it linear population or is it a job I
guess it could be arbitrary but yeah so
at the moment it is by default linear
interpolation there is some degree of
control that you have over which
interpolation and the plan is to expand
that control over which interpolation
by which interpolation you mean so two
bookmarks could have three controls that
are in different states right so in
other words x equals one y equals two Z
equals three and then the next one's
something else right and so clearly
there is multi many paths to get from
one XYZ point to another XYZ Point
um now the point is from the
specification language so I thought
about that too you know the if you only
want one control to move at the time
which is what you do when you manually
manipulate the controls
then the state that you're going to
interpolate between should only move one
control
if you if yeah if you change the setup
to move simultaneously several controls
we can do that with interpolation but
you can't manually do it unless you have
like three hands yeah right but I mean
that's what we could do with game pads
for example we did have waves we do have
ways to simultaneously change multiple
controls right that still work yeah
but so
okay but but often okay like your thing
here
um or or a bunch of dead I wrote too
they're more than one
you can kind of see the Simplicity of it
if you kind of clearly Define some setup
start here then change this then change
that and it becomes obvious the thing
that you wanted to explain I understand
kind of like an experiment or like a
scene or something like that can I ask
something about about in scripts and
things or storyboards or whatever about
camera moves and so on so if you say I
don't know all the terms you know Dolly
to here et cetera et cetera et cetera
does it how do you say you know like as
the person says you know uh
uh there's something amazing here you
know and you zoom in on the person or
whatever is there a way of representing
the fact that as they start saying that
you're zoomed out and by the time
they've finished saying it you fully
zoomed in is there some notation for
that or something some way of describing
that
I mean those are the names of the moves
that you you know no I know I'm kind of
pushing that is that some is there some
way that you would write that if you you
know in a whatever I don't know what the
right term is a storyboard or something
you know to describe that doing that
that that's what the final video is
going to look like is there a way to
describe that right I mean you were
pretty much saying it right it's zoom in
zoom out pan left pan right till there's
a lot of things will be written in the
description so if it's a storyboard
underneath each cell of of like a visual
it would say give direction on what's
happening there and then it would be up
to the discretion of the the director as
it's being
produced to see it and see how it's
going to work I mean in traditional
production
but I mean so but what I'm asking is if
during the time when something is being
said you want a camera to have moved in
a particular way zoomed in for example
is there a standard way or does it just
say
sort of in two separate threads it says
on you know one place that says you know
zooming in on the the you know pet
dragon or something and then and then
somebody is saying you know the dragon
is saying there's something amazing here
or whatever
um and the the that it's then you know
up to the director you know at that
moment to sort of say zoom and and
finish your zoom and just say in words
you know finish your Zoom when the when
the dragon has finished talking type
thing is that is that what would happen
or is there some more formal notation
for that that would in that would be
more like uh just specific time stamps
just to denote like if you're working on
production that's going to be used for a
30 second ad you would it would be very
specific and narrowed in it would just
be time stamps just traditional General
time stamps okay but then but then when
the voiceover is given and the person
you know has 22 seconds to read that how
does that usually work does the person
read it and then you figure out how the
zoom is going to work or do you have the
zoom and then you Time Stretch and or
whatever the what the person says or or
you have a person who's really good at
reading it in exactly 22 seconds
yeah a lot of that's pre-production
planning so it could work either way it
could be where you end up time
stretching the footage or
or it's just that you coordinated it
well and advanced and were able to make
it work
okay all right so what does that mean
for what we're doing here I mean
recognizing by the way that a lot of
these kind of video Direction type
things in the in the time of llms there
are going to be more and more automated
ways to deal with this
I mean I've already seen I mean you know
they're they're already sort of Proto
examples of text to video type stuff
although they're not particularly good
yet I think
um I mean
uh even in with real camera moves when
you you know when you don't do CGI
um they use robots to
sure to very precisely you know control
the the camera path and those you know
also
controls the camera so zoom and things
like that right but the the points that
I guess we're making up to what we are
proposing here like defining key
positions and then interpolating between
those yeah we're trying to build the
simplistic right but right the point
that I keep on coming to is for many of
the things that people want to build as
videos from manipulates they're going to
want voiceovers and I'm trying to
understand how on Earth we merge those
in yeah so I think I think one of the
things that uh you seem uh to think that
I don't know maybe Bob has an opinion if
that is uh the majority of cases or not
is that the generation of the video and
the voiceover happens at one time I was
under the assumption that a lot of the
times the video is generated first and
then the voiceover is recorded uh by
looking at the video someone enunciating
while looking at the video and recording
doing that to ensure synchronization
well I'm sure that's true I mean isn't
that what you know when when you know
movies are scored or whatever you know
don't they don't they have you know the
orchestra watching the movie when
they're doing things
what I'm saying is this would work with
a real person enunciating but obviously
it would not work with automated speech
synthesis so I think I'm not sure it
would work with a real person because I
mean you know if you allow yourself 22
seconds for this Zoom
and you've written some text
and by golly that text takes 34 seconds
to say it's not going to work
no but I'm assuming like if if the text
somehow fits those are okay it won't it
won't because nobody's going to know
just to change the text right but
nobody's gonna know it's no it's going
to look like this it's going to be
here's what's going to happen it's gonna
and I've seen people do this right it's
gonna move it's going to go to the the
end point and the person's going to say
look at it moving
silence because it's still moving at the
point where they finished saying let it
look at it moving right silent silent
silence
five seconds later it's finished moving
oh let's see what it did
three second pause so I mean with a
design we can address kind of all of
that let's say that you wanted to go
from State 1 to state two and you have
some voiceover that you want to incur
there yep okay so you want them to line
up somehow so for instance
uh let's say that you use speech
synthesis with normal speed and not sort
of
Legally speed
uh right that gives you a time exactly
you know that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying I mean that is that is
one way to do it is what I was
describing for the slideshow right yeah
that is easy to to do by just Computing
durations and I mean exactly that but
but that is something that is
speech synthesized computation figure
out what the time marks are done exactly
and you know and make sure there's
appropriate padding so you're not
running the sentences yeah configurable
setting as well
um but yeah
yeah that's reasonable
I think that
um if we're looking at manipulator
manipulate video still kind of hints at
keeping the two aspects separate like
this the synthesis
uh and then being able to pass the
audios to the generation I'm not buying
it I'm not buying this I just don't
think this is right because I think the
durations are in many cases as soon as
there's an audio track the durations are
going to be determined by the audio
and and also I mean I think that we
could make a design where it's it's
you know that manipulate video If you
give sort of time and states
and if you also give another thing
that's marked up to be
that generates speech or an audio file
whichever you care for exactly
um then
then there could be either default that
says you know that's the that's the time
to take plus padding
um
or there's something that says you know
add more right so one way to do this
would be I think maybe this is exactly
what you were saying you know this this
time Mark now the one thing is it's sort
of a fence post thing because these are
the betweens right you've got a you know
a state
you've got it's between which could be
three seconds just the raw number or it
could be this audio file whatever its
duration is yeah
right
the thing that's bugging me is this okay
and maybe I'm being silly about this
I'm trying to understand if it's all
about waypoints
you know maybe it's okay maybe it's okay
if it's probably if the motion is
properly parametrized
what I'm what I'm worried about is that
it's kind of like you have to have
finished your yours your
what if you have a piece of audio that
is supposed to span four waypoints
that's what I'm saying it goes from here
to there to there to there and as it's
going around those waypoints you're
giving a little speech yeah so you're
getting closer and closer to my original
which is more like
uh kind of like a a an orchestral piece
where you
you know orchestrating a lot of stuff
I think that we were trying to get to
right now is something that's a a real
easy spec and then building out from
there
elaborates okay but let's go through
this I mean basically what we're saying
is
and have we had to address this issue in
other places where we have state
state to state to state but I mean it's
like in a graph we have edges and we
have vertices
right how we had to do that for audio
for any purpose of having you know a
state or video for that matter a state
and then things in between
didn't we have to do that for tour video
yeah yeah
and uh uses
um
um that essentially just takes the
approach that we just use the keyframes
just the times rather than just the
verses rather than the edges
okay but the problem is let me let me
point out into a video we're going to
have the exact same issue except yeah
video so if you wanted to annotate that
with text I mean like speech to sorry
text to speech or audio
one could put that in instead of those
time steps right
then
I'm saying the Second Use case there
whether it's time time
well but I don't think so because it
goes in right here it's the thing that
goes between these two I mean it seems
like it would make more sense like its
vertices and edges listed in a graph
although this is just linear right to
have a separate list a third element
here which is the audio for example for
every one of those
I mean what one possibility would be
that you have in this thing you say to a
video or let's just show slideshow video
it doesn't matter either of them right
and then when I get do next
is to say comma
you know Audio One Audio Two
right those are the audios
for
those durations between this and this
and then maybe what we could do I mean
I'm sure slideshow video has a a Time
step type thing does it not
um
that's that second syntax you're looking
at
yeah right so so then what we would do
oh slideshow video was slightly
different we looked at it last time
okay but it has this mhd here it is
really durations there because those are
very static right
whereas the other ones
you might be rotating and translating
there is action happening yeah okay
slideshow there's no action happening
it's just flip to the next slide but
either way
you could say
like we do with sound note and things at
this time marker start going yak yak yak
I mean by the way sound note is a model
of this yeah I mean it's kind of but
it's a little bit more elaborate and
sound note is it what I'm saying because
you're trying to
synchronize different things I know I
know I know so that's the problem is
that that we could say here comma
automatic for this dt1
and then it could pick up its time from
the duration of such and such an audio
do you get what I'm saying yeah
the problem I see with that is when you
want one of the audios to span two of
the things you have or multiple of the
things you have in that first argument I
know so right so that's why it's tricky
I mean and maybe we have to name
a score is the word that I was looking
for what's that
score you know when you write yeah yeah
yeah right and there things can happen
simultaneously or not I know but I don't
know the notations I mean
you know that all of these music
notations but they tend to be start at
this time go for this time
go for this number of of uh you know
beats or whatever
yeah it's all relative right so you can
speed up or slow down the whole thing
right but that's that's never absolutely
stuff works as well but it doesn't work
for voices we can't we're not going to
be able to do that
but I think what what we want to do here
is
it takes a little bit more thought but I
think what's going to be needed is
those times that you're specifying here
are really
but times to
uh
times to audio marks whatever I don't is
there a term for that
in other words I'm reading
hello this is the Earth
hello this is a this is a speedboat
right each of those things there's some
kind of marker at the end of what I've
said hello this is the earth type thing
do those have does that have a name in
in video production Bob anybody we just
call it a queue
what is what does it mean what does a q
mean a q just means that's the time at
which something's going to happen
correct
okay
so okay so that's what we're talking
about here is we're defining certain
cues
and a queue
when that cue occurs would be determined
by how long the audio took to say
by the fair characterization
in other words you say q q the speed
boat or something and is that the right
terminology I don't even know what that
is that the right way to say it yeah
that works
okay so then then
that would mean now it's time to put the
speed boat on
and that Q is determined by how long it
took to say here's the Earth
this making sense to people so I mean
what we would have is a list
not of times but of cues
and then we would say
kind of what determines each queue based
on audio
is that making sense to people
shoddy I'm really starting to see a Daw
kind of a thing an interactive thing
with multiple tracks multiple pieces and
segments in each of those tracks
um
and and I can see that immediately in a
one line of function how can we
specify that but overall I think we are
at least we know how what we want to
combine we don't know what kind of a
syntax would work for us no no no the
syntax is a little bit tricky and I
don't quite see it yet okay right but
but I think what we're all saying is
there are certain
you know shots or something which might
just be a static slide on the screen it
might be something which is you know
moving sliders to get from here to there
in some trajectory
okay
and there might be a series of shots
and
the length of that series of shots will
be determined by a piece of audio
so it might be three shots and we say
distribute them you know have them of
equal length
in the time it takes to say
hello you know
welcome to
the solar system or something
you see what I'm saying
[Music]
and
because I I really think this idea maybe
maybe I'm wrong but and somebody can
correct me but this idea of time is
determined by how things are spoken
seems really quite useful for what we're
trying to do here I mean I agree I would
not forget though decays where we're
just generating video and we don't have
any any audio and the plan is generally
a video to the demonstration project for
example and then do the post-production
and editing in an external software and
that I understand that but not really
difficult okay so in the external
software we could Time Warp the video if
we needed to right so you fill in the
voiceover and then you Time Warp the
video is that we can we can do it as
well
I'm not talking time working just I
don't know adjusting colors adding the
voiceover whatever I'm just saying you
can't add voiceover if if the thing if
the video you recorded took three
seconds well I mean
what's that things hopefully the
director a programmatic director or
whatever
um but know what they would say and
David know how long an athlete would
take right and the planning for the
video would be sensible rather than
produce something completely unusable
I I I don't know what um
um
uh
yeah I think I'm in the process of
losing my voice which is very odd
um
I don't know maybe I got sick yeah
um what I'm saying is the audio case is
useful and interesting and and
definitely should be discussed I'm just
saying let's not leave the just video
generation behind no I agree but the
video generation is with pure time marks
three seconds to do this and so on
that's what we need I just I'm just
saying that I think it is super useful
to be able to
you know and and we'd have a workflow by
the way where a human could record you
know this audio file it requires this so
it requires three audio files you know
for this thing
you know record them then stick them in
here
now
yeah okay we need to wrap up but but I
think so there's a little bit of design
thinking here about how these cues and
uh you know the the Gap type thing is
going to work right because it's got to
be a spanning thing it's got to have you
know and perhaps in the score idea it's
like the three elements here and maybe
the way we do it is we say just like we
do in a table we say it's this one and
there's audio that starts here and then
it spans this one for example
if you get what I'm saying span from
left type thing right
um because I don't think you know having
the audio stop halfway through no we
don't need to do that that's that's too
detailed
but we might want it spanning multiple
things
so we could have
a much like sound note we could have
intrinsic times there and if the audio
you know doesn't follow those times we
could Time Warp the um the video so to
speak
but in other words if the Earth was up
for two seconds and the speed rope was
up for one second and it turned out that
the audio was 4.2 seconds long you could
Time Warp those two times correct so
that it fitted 4.2 seconds so so let me
give a partial proposal not very well
thought out or anything but okay CD we
have a manipulate that has some amount
of name bookmarks and then we have a
bunch of audio recordings uh what if we
have uh to indicate the evolution of the
video in its soundtrack just uh time
goes to bookmark and time goes to audio
and these would be placed completely
independently
um
and and the duration of the audio would
count it would be maintained uh but I
don't understand that I don't know
zero seconds or you want instead of zero
second bookmark two starts at two
seconds but Audio Two starts at four
seconds no it won't work no because what
we need to have is that the duration of
audio one is what determines the second
mark
the second time Mark okay but that that
doesn't work if we want audio to span
overlapping uh differently yes it does
yes it does all you do is in the thing
you'd say you know
the
you'd say let's say we've got this we'd
say Audio One audio two and then we
would say that let's imagine we have
another you know a couple another
picture let's put another speedboat
there
um
okay then what we would do is we would
say Audio One
span from left let's say a bad word
Audio Two
okay what does that mean that means
audio one is continuing through this
first speedboat
but what if you want audio to to start
in the middle between uh of the time
where the speedboat is decided then
you've got it over time marks
I'm saying you get to yours you see I
see these both be complemental a
potential syntaxes that could go in the
same function right
like this and if not you do time one
goes to audio one time two goes to Audio
Two
that's fine okay that's fine but what
I'm saying is I think it's really
important to have this kind of just
sequence sequence sequence thing so
you're proposing a way to closely align
the audio to the slides and and if you
want to disengage that alignment you
just specify the times yeah exactly so
so in other words normally it would just
be you list the audios and they default
to
you know
right so so this would be audio one
plays through the end of that speedboat
then it's Audio Two playing
through this slide
an audio three through this slide now
when it comes to the manipulate case
we've got this you know vertices and
edges problem
because the the length the number of
elements here will be one less than the
number of waypoints
to get what I'm saying
yep
I mean unless we hold the last
um Waypoint which we shouldn't do which
we shouldn't do because people are not
always going to want it if you want to
hold it you put it in there twice yeah
yeah that's fair
the
um
I think this looks pretty good and I
think we should make a function for this
and we should try it out with speech
synthesize yeah so there are a couple of
things right that need to happen one
that the internals of manipulate need to
start supporting all of this that will
be Step Zero that is Step okay but you
can do all this audio stuff with
slideshow as well and with animation
video and so on you could you could
start putting that in
um
okay right animation video
is just a one-piece thing at this point
one what one piece it doesn't have
multiple pieces
no I understand that but you could put
in one audio thing and the animation
could happen not at an absolute time but
at the time that it took you to say yak
yak yak sure
seems useful to me I don't know I mean I
I don't know does Bob want to comment on
on this whole General approach of
synchronizing you know of audios and
videos synchronizing and so on does this
seem useful or is this like no we never
use that because we'd always have to
tweak it by hand
no I'm actually interested in trying it
out I think I think most of the time
when I'm producing like a explainer
video or something that I do start with
the outline of course but then the audio
gets voice over will get produced and
then
you know the clip getting
adjusted to fit the voice over so I mean
you're on the right track I believe at
the same time Carlo mentioned this once
let me reiterate a lot of the times my
understanding same as Carlos is that
audio Edition happens as a separate step
for animation video and slideshow video
it's really easy to say what should be
the duration of the whole thing or small
pieces of the slideshow video for
instance and then that duration could be
exactly the duration of an audio that is
pre-generated right we want to
smush all of these into these functions
yes we do because we're trying to get
something okay look I'm planning for the
time when audio generation voice over
generation is really good automatically
which I don't think is far away
see what I'm saying with the services
that we're adding it is already pretty
good uh but okay so so like for example
if we could train it on one of us okay
and we could you know we could have the
Carlo explainer video
I trained on your voice for example
that's coming within you know within the
year
and it'll be quite good
in my view
and you know right now we probably have
it for some standardized voices
and you know and that's what I'm and
then we can you know it becomes very
very fast to generate videos
from you know from demonstrations and so
on
that makes sense
yep I guess out of a new world it's it's
not the world where you have to do video
editing every single time you want to
produce a video
right currency what you're asking is one
option in these video generations and a
video combined after what you're
proposing that we add is this kind of a
second argument in so many functions
some of which already have second third
well I know so I've got to look through
it I don't know how to do that I'm not
solving that problem you've got to look
through it to figure out how this works
maybe it's an option I don't know
okay
okay I need to go to something else
we're going to need to come back on this
another time can you please think
through what it's going to take to put
these in what we did not address here
was the name manipulate video which I
don't like at all and
um
what what are some alternatives to the
name manipulate video
if you open the page I think I put one
or two other things
I mean it's kind of like tour video
isn't it no
um my suggestions in the notebook are
bad this is in a sense to our video Bob
you were suggesting something else in
email
interpolation video interpolate video I
just but they're all interpolate videos
right right so you know and they're all
keyframes you know all of these things
that we we are producing are sort of
easy specs a lot of automations
and they all right interpolate to
varying degrees
and they're all keyframe to varying
degrees so we can't it's a tour video is
really an image tour video
yeah or graphics and maybe we should
change it to be image it can as well be
a video to video where the video is
moving and then we originally but
um but yeah I see your point it it can
have a different name
the problem is
or manipulate as a noun is really just
an us thing it's very hard to understand
true
um
and we're planning a two or three D
video right that does the same in 3D
okay
well I mean this is
you know it's more like a controls video
or something
because we do have the term controls
that we use in connection with
manipulate
we do
and really what the thing is doing is it
is picking up certain controls and
moving them around
I really need to go I'm sorry um I mean
we're getting that I think that's closer
controls video seems more useful
your comments
I'm thinking the word animate we do have
animation video but animated video
some something with animate might be the
whole point is that what this is doing
is moving some controls around
automatically
okay controls animation video or
something well obviously when I hear
controls I don't think of those but I
know when you control the plural you
don't think of control theory
necessarily
someone had proposed manipulate two
video I'm not sure that makes it any
better but no it doesn't also cloochy
I I'm the one that I'm liking best right
now how about the exploration video
maybe and this is you know we we take
and manipulate and we we create an
exploration
yeah I understand
I I like this concept somehow of moving
controls
because I think that might even be more
General than manipulate
maybe not it's because manipulate is the
thing that attaches an actual symbol
name to these things
I think we should do a little bit more
okay let's bring this back in the next
few days
um
and uh
okay
uh all right we should wrap up here
um all right good stuff guys but but
we're going to need to come back to this
one more time here okay
thanks thank you bye